foreign
you
you
you
republican leader asking something
further proceeded on the quorum call be
dispensed with
without objection on good friday
the united states capitol police were
subjected
to another violent attack
once again our uniform heroes
wound up in harm's way and officer billy
evans
a friend and favorite of many here on
the senate side
a faithful protector of the capitol was
killed
investigators are still assessing what
drove the perpetrator to attempt this
attack on the capitol
and whether domestic violent extremism
played a role
he appears to have been captivated by
the
nation of islam a racist anti-semitic
extreme group under the openly
openly hateful leader louis farrakhan
his attack injured officer ken shaver
and it stole away the life
of officer evans from his children logan
and abigail
his mother janice his entire family
and all of his friends and colleagues
decades
too soon officer evans was famous within
the senate for his friendly spirit
and easy manner he was the first face
that many would see on their way to work
here in the capitol every day his
particular
post often met he was literally the
first line of defense
of the congress the interface
between these grounds and the outside
world
we could not have had a kinder more
likable ambassador
at this junction or a more faithful
protector
to keep us safe it will be with
tremendous grief but
tremendous gratitude it will welcome
officer evans to the capitol of final
time tomorrow
where he will lie in honor in the
rotunda
i think i speak for the entire senate
when i salute all of our u.s capitol
police officers
for the heroism courage and resilience
they displayed
the friday before last in which they
display every single day
the senate and the nation are profoundly
grateful for your selfless
service now on a completely
different matter the senate returns
today from a state work period
we got to meet with constituents in our
home states and hear firsthand
about their most pressing concerns
unfortunately back here in washington
democrats continued to roll out new
reasons
for the american people to worry
the week before last the biden
administration unveiled their latest
misleadingly titled legislation
this time under the supposed veil of
infrastructure the white house has
lumped together
a motley assortment assortment of the
left's
priciest priorities this plan would
impose the biggest
one of the biggest tax hikes in a
generation
when workers need an economic recovery
it would gut right to work protections
for blue-collar workers
it would throw hundreds of billions at
the far less green fads
they even want to include a special
state and local tax provision designed
to overwhelmingly benefit
wealthy residents of blue states
less than six percent of this proposal
goes to roads and bridges
it's not remotely targeted toward what
americans think
they're getting when politicians
campaign
on infrastructure but instead of coming
up with a better bill democrats have
decided
it's the english language that has to
change they're embarking on an orwellian
campaign to convince
everybody that any government policy
whatsoever can be labeled
infrastructure liberals just have to
believe
in it hard enough
these trojan horse tactics have become a
pattern
many of our democratic colleagues are
trying to rewrite 50 state election laws
from here in washington
not a partisan takeover of the federal
election commission
but call the whole mess a quote voting
rights bill
end quote the white house
claims about state election regulations
keep getting disproven by fact truckers
but even so some of the wealthiest and
most powerful institutions in our
country
have bowed down to the fake narratives
and decided to amplify
the misstatements themselves
so look madam president i'm as strong a
supporter of the first amendment in free
speech as anyone in this body
i have been for many years if people
want to participate in debate through
political speech
that's certainly their constitutional
right even if they fall
for disinformation but it's one thing to
act like free speakers within a debate
it's very different to try to
short-circuit the debate
to shut down the debate through economic
bullying
of american citizens the last two weeks
also brought more troubling signs from
our southern border
last month closed with customs and
border patrol reporting the highest
total for migrant apprehensions
in nearly two decades but while
republican senators traveled to the
border
met with officials and learned about the
reality on the ground the administration
has preferred to inaccurately blame this
recent spike
on their predecessors
finally finally last week the white
house rolled out a new budget
proposal i've been a supporter of
secretary blinken
and other officials tough talk with the
people's republic of china
and with putin again massing forces on
ukraine's border administration
officials have been right right to warn
against
further russian aggression
this budget outline was going to be one
of the first real tests to see if the
administration was prepared to walk the
walk
and put sufficient funding toward our
military and strategic competition
with china and russia both of which have
invested heavily in military
capabilities
that threaten our forces unfortunately
for all the rhetoric
the president has asked congress to
break from the positive trajectory of
the last four years and instead cut
defense spending
after inflation that's going backward
on national defense this would undermine
recent bipartisan
progress put the modernization of
american forces in jeopardy
and help china toward their goal of
overtaking the united states as the
world's
preeminent superpower this budget
proposal sent a clear signal to the rest
of the world
and unfortunately it suggests to our
allies from eastern europe to the south
china sea
that american resolve is far from
guaranteed
on all these issues there's broad and
deep bipartisan interest in working
together
infrastructure legislation that actually
focuses
on infrastructure voting legislation
that actually makes it easier to vote
and harder to cheat and funding
legislation
that provides the pentagon with what it
needs to keep up with china russia
and other adversaries legislation on all
these topics
have a track record of earning
overwhelming bipartisan support
all these issues are ripe for regular
order
bipartisan work if the president and our
democratic colleagues
are interested in going about them in
the right way
but if the administration decides to
reprise
their topics from february and march if
democrats just declare
our way or the highway we'll know they
have chosen to create political
controversies
rather than make progress for american
families
i suggest absolute forum clear quote
called world
mrs baldwin
senator from alabama i ask unanimous
consent to withdraw the quorum
without objection madam president once
again i'm here today to talk about the
crisis at our southern border
and the continued dismantling of our
nation's immigration system
by this administration the border has
been dominating the headlines
but if you talk to the liberals you
would know it
well we're back home working in our
states democrats focused on everything
but the border
president biden released a so-called
infrastructure proposal
that's not actually about infrastructure
it's nothing more than the green new
deal
in disguise it raises taxes on
hard-working
americans additionally large
corporations
and major league baseball decided to
give in to the demands
of the woke liberal mob based on nothing
more
than pure disinformation i know
president biden and democrats
would rather talk about those issues
than confront the dire situation
at the southern border they're trying to
pull a con job on the american people
well we're not going to let president
biden distract
from a crisis of his own making
in a recent house hearing department of
homeland security
secretary mayorkas made a ridiculous
claim
that quote the border is secure
to say the border is secure is laughable
i recently joined senators cornyn and
cruz
and other colleagues on a visit to the
southern border to see for ourselves
and i can tell you and the american
people without hesitation
the border is not secure
reports just don't do it justice
it is a disaster as an american
who believes in the rule of law i was
embarrassed
this is not a democrat or a republican
problem
it is an american problem this crisis
is a stain on our nation
what we saw on our trip broke my heart
so many young unaccompanied children
sent on a dangerous journey north
by their parents because this
administration
promised to take them in the compassion
shown by the border patrol agents
was clear these brave men and women
are doing all they can to make the best
out of a terrible situation
a situation created by our president and
his administration
i've said it before and i'll say it
again
the situation happening at our southern
border was predictable
and preventable border patrol
folks know this will happen
and that would happen they told us how
they asked the biden administration
before the inauguration
to give them time to prepare for any
changes
to the immigration policy but president
biden didn't listen
he was more interested in appeasing the
globalist
who demanded he immediately end
president trump's successful border
policies
on his first day in office president
biden reversed president trump's
policies and signaled to the world that
the american border
was open president biden gave border
patrol
little to no warning the result
has been a border that's not run
by the united states it is run by the
mexican cartel
and human smugglers what's worse
it's not just people that are coming in
illegally
i was down at the border i saw firsthand
how criminals take advantage
of the situation cartels sent migrants
to persist
to specific locations along the border
to preoccupy
law enforcement while moving illegal
drugs
at other crossing points on a midnight
visit to the rio grande these
traffickers actually taunted us
from across the river yelling and
flashing their lights
they know the biden administration is
unwilling
to confront them and because the
administration won't confront them
we've seen massive increases in drug
seizures
in january and february alone customs
and border protection seizures of
fentanyl
were up 277
compared to the same time in 2020
cocaine seized at the border is up 62
percent
and remember whether it's people or
drugs
these numbers only account for those we
catch
there are many more drug runners that
get through undetected
secretary marcus has said the
administration goal
is safe legal
and orderly immigration system well so
far
he and they have failed on all three
the immigration system under the obama
administration
is not safe by encouraging
migrants to come to the border president
biden has empowered
the drug cartels and coyotes who prey on
desperate people
according to mexican intelligent
assessments it cost
an unaccompanied central american minor
between
three and ten thousand dollars to secure
across uh to be secured across the u.s
border
an open border also invites wolves in
sheep's clothing
according to customs border patrol
protection at least
four people have been arrested in the
last few months
at the border who match names on the
fbi's
terrorist screening database there's no
doubt
those who wish harm will take advantage
of this crisis to infiltrate
our country the biden administration
also is enforcing the laws is not
enforcing the laws
written by congress that's why i joined
with 39 of my republican colleagues to
send a letter
to the nonpartisan government
accountability office
to investigate president biden's un
un lateral decision to freeze funds
for the border wall congress
specifically
appropriated funds for the border wall
construction
i believe the president's actions
infringe on congress's constitutional
power of the purse i hope the gao
will quickly look into this so we can
begin to restore
border security finally the immigration
system
under the by administration is not
orderly
in fact it's chaotic our border patrol
agents
are overwhelmed in march of this year
border patrol
arrested more than 170
000 migrants crossing the border
illegally
that's the worst month in 15 years
to put that in perspective for the folks
back home that means there are more
illegal migrants rushing our border in
one month
then the entire population of lee county
alabama
where i live last month
more than 18 700
unaccompanied minors were taken into
custody by the border patrol
that's double the number they
encountered
in february this chaos is due
entirely to president biden's careless
words and foolish
policies the biden administration is
content
to let all who come here illegally stay
that is a recipe for disaster
the result is a border catastrophe
i've spoken previously about common
sense actions to secure the border
such as continuing to build a wall and
reinstated
migrant protection protocols here's one
more
i recently introduced a bill that would
require dhs
to issue a notice to appear called an
nta to every migrant that is processed
at the border
we cannot we cannot continue
to release illegal immigrants into our
country without establishing
some accountability such as a date for
immigration court
at best it hurts who came to this
country
actually looking to plead their asylum
case
at worst it's given a free reign to
those who enter our country
illegally the biden administration says
they want
humane and compassionate improvements to
our immigration system
releasing someone without a mta is
neither
my bill also requires the department of
homeland security
to revoke any status and work
authorization from a migrant
who doesn't show up for their court date
this mandate will curb the pull factors
embedded in our immigration system
and cut down on incentives for illegal
immigration it's a small but meaningful
step
it's about restoring integrity in our
immigration
system president biden has made weak
attempts
to turn back the tide of migrants even
telling them
quote don't come president biden's
actions
speak louder than those two feeble words
well mr president as we say in alabama
you're a day
late and a dollar short
my my republican colleagues and i will
continue to demand
action from the president on this crisis
on behalf
of the legal citizens of the united
states
of america i stand ready to work
with the president and his
administration on common sense
solutions secure the border
strengthen national security and protect
the american people
madam president i yield the floor
madam president senator from wyoming
thank you madam president first amount
of president i'd like to associate
myself with the refined remarks of the
senator from alabama
because i too come to talk about the
crisis on our southern border
the senator from alabama and i traveled
together along with senator cruz and
senator corden
just a few weeks ago we had i think
total of 19
senators uh that uh went to see the
crisis
firsthand and um in fact it's not just
one crisis as the senator from alabama
and i have
both spoken about it's a double crisis
it's a national security crisis
as well as a humanitarian crisis
we went on a midnight midnight patrol
and what did we see at midnight
well we saw and we heard not just did we
see the lights on on the other side of
the rio grande we heard the cat calls
from traffickers who are taunting our
u.s border patrol agents
saying in spanish you cannot stop us now
that is what we're hearing from the
criminals and the traffickers
across the rio grande we saw
signs on the ground directing migrants
to the facilities
where they will then turn themselves in
and we spoke to the border patrol agents
they told us that their jobs got an
awful lot harder on january 20th which
was the day joe biden became president
of the united states president biden
flipped over the sign and sent the clear
message around the world that said the
united states border
is now wide open because of that clear
message
border patrol arrests and detentions
have doubled
since january in march border patrol
took
171 000 migrants
into custody nearly 19 000 of those are
unaccompanied minors that's an all-time
record in the united states and the pace
that we're on now is to get to
two million illegal immigrants crossing
our border
this very year
to this secretary of homeland security
nominated by president biden
this is the most in 20 years
the most in 20 years right now this year
under president biden
the biden white house has essentially
told the world anyone under 18 can cross
our border and we will let you
in so it's no surprise that today we are
seeing a historic
influx of children
of teenagers crossing our border
two-thirds of the border patrol agents
the border patrol agents tell us
two-thirds of them
can't do their regular jobs because they
are too busy babysitting these children
or escort adults area will turn
themselves in
more to different border patrol custody
than ever before and in the day of the
global pandemic
i will tell you as i was in the senators
in a location designed for 250 during a
during coronavirus there were 7 000
crammed in like sardines
with the foil blankets to huddle under
no social distancing none
at all this is a biden
created humanitarian crisis
under the law children can only be in
border patrol custody for 72 hours
we won't want our own children there for
72 minutes
yet there are thousands and thousands in
custody
for over 10 days and 10
of the young people being tested or
testing positive for coronavirus we
watched the testing in the courtyard
where i was
they were all together and then they
tested some and they said okay you test
negative you go that way you test
positive you go that way
but absolutely every one of them was
exposed to each other
so the fact that 10 percent are testing
positive it's highly likely that the
remainder will test positive
as well and what's the biden
administration doing about that
they're sending those young people
either those people just exposed to
coronavirus just standing right next to
somebody with coronavirus
sending them all across the country
exposed to whoever knows what strain of
coronavirus
it was and so this is
a humanitarian crisis but madam
president i will tell you it is also a
national security crisis
the department of homeland security has
now arrested two men from the country of
yemen who are on the terrorist
watch list border patrol says
they were apprehending people not just
central america and mexico
they have apprehended people from 56
different countries there at the border
since president biden has taken the oath
of office last week border patrol agents
outside san diego
san diego arrested a member of ms-13
one of the most vicious criminal gangs
in the world now these are just a couple
of examples that we know about
imagine things we don't know about the
people that haven't been caught people
who are roaming among us
today in the united states that's what i
hear about in wyoming i've just been
home for two weeks talking to people
this is the number one topic
that i heard about traveling the state
of wyoming so we have two crises at the
southern border
the humanitarian crisis and the national
security crisis
president biden has caused them both and
president
biden can stop them
yet the biden administration is still in
denial
it refuses to even admit that there is a
crisis
president biden still hasn't been to the
border neither is the vice president
and she's supposed to be in charge of
finding a solution to the problem
so once again today i call on president
biden
and vice president harris to go to the
border
and face the truth today
is the day go to the border face
the truth
the president vice president should talk
to the border patrol agents
they should hear the stories that they
heard that we've heard from them
it's the stories that they want to tell
they need to hear these stories they
need to face the reality
madam president border patrol agents
told me directly
finish the wall bring back the remain in
mexico policy
because those are things that will make
a difference
until we do those two things the jobs of
the border patrol agents
will continue to get tougher and tougher
every day
vast vast numbers vast majorities of
american people support the border
patrol agents i know there are people on
the other side of the aisle that want to
eliminate
immigration and custom enforcement want
to get rid of the border
line and have people that are patrolling
the border want to get rid of it all
when open borders fully and
without the kind of national security
that we need at our borders
but according to the associated press
only one in four americans
approves of how president biden is
handling
the border situation president biden
should listen to the american people
we need change at the border we need it
today we cannot wait our national
security cannot wait
the humanitarian crisis must be met
and dealt with republicans are going to
continue to offer common sense solutions
that will make a real difference
at the border we want to finish the wall
we want to bring back the remain in
mexico policy
we want to stem this crisis the
humanitarian
crisis and the national security crisis
that is facing our nation today
we stand for enforcing the law for
closing the loopholes
that encourage illegal immigration we
want to secure the border so i would
urge
president biden and all of my democrat
colleagues
to please face the facts join us in our
effort
it's time to bring this crisis to
an end thank you madam president
i yield the floor suggest the absence of
a quorum
clerk called world miss baldwin
president maturity leader i ask
unanimous consent the quorum be
dispensed with
without objection now madam president
the senate returns to session
in the shadow of tragedy a week ago
last friday a senseless attack on the
capital by a lone actor injured one
capital police officer
and claimed the life of another officer
william
billy evans all of us in the capitol
all of us across the nation wish for the
speedy recovery of officer shaver
and mourn the loss of another fallen
hero
to pay tribute to his final act of
bravery officer evans
will lie in honor under the capital
rotunda
at the very center of the democracy he
gave his life to protect
a service in his memory will take place
tomorrow morning
for everyone who works in the senate his
loss is particularly painful
he was a familiar face who greeted
lawmakers reporters staffers and
employees at the north entrance
as we entered the senate side of the
building whether you knew him or not
his wide smile was often the first thing
you'd see in the morning
this has been an immensely difficult few
months for members of the capitol police
force
and for everyone who works behind the
scenes to safeguard
the capital complex senate committees
are conducting bipartisan and
comprehensive reviews to ensure the
capital is secure
as possible while also remaining
accessible
to the public that's a top priority
but also in this moment of profound loss
we need to comfort each other and
support members of the capitol police
who in
four short months suffered a brutal
attack by a violent mob
and lost four of their friends and
cherished colleagues
we must never never take for granted the
work they do day in and day out
to guard the citadel of democracy
i have more i'll have more to say
tomorrow when we pay tribute
to the life of officer evans for now
i wish to extend my deep condolences to
his
friends and family especially his two
young children
and everyone whose lives were enriched
by knowing this incredible
incredible public servant
now on an entirely another matter
as the senate returns to work this week
we're going to pick back right up
where we left off aggressively filling
the biden administration with
well-qualified nominees
and pursuing timely legislation that
meets the needs of the american people
this week the senate will vote on the
nominations of polly trottenberg to
serve as deputy
secretary of transportation when
determined to serve as deputy secretary
of state
gary gensler to serve on the security
and exchange commission
and brenda mallory to be a member of the
council on environmental quality
each is exceptionally well qualified for
their respective position
and each i expect will receive
bipartisan support here on the floor
and i'm particularly proud of polly
trottenberg
who is my legislative director and
legislative assistant on transportation
i believe for it was nine years she then
served as secretary
of as rather commissioner of
transportation in new york city
and one of the things of course madam
president
that i talked to her about regularly was
getting gateway
our much-needed tunnel built under the
hudson so needed by new york new jersey
and the entire northeast
corridor the senate will also develop
debate on legislation from senator
hirono and representative meng
to address the surge of anti-asian hate
crimes
during the covet pandemic over the past
year
we've read horrible accounts of violence
and discrimination against asian
americans
spurred on by ignorance and xenophobia
and the vicious slander
that blames the chinese people for covet
19.
slander that was often encouraged and
repeated so regrettably so
i so regret that that a president would
stoop to that level
but it was encouraged and repeated by
the former president
who seems to almost revel in advance in
advancing bigotry
sadly the recent spate of anti-asian
violence
is not a new chapter in american history
from the chinese massacre of 1871
to the explicitly racist chinese
exclusion act
the internment of japanese american
citizens
and the shameful koromatsu supreme court
decision
the asian-american community has long
suffered the hammer blows
of racism bigotry we cannot let this new
surge which contains echoes of these
violent chapters in our history
go unaddressed so this week
the senate will vote on senator hirono's
anti-asian hate crimes bill
the bill does two things i know madam
president that you are a sponsor a proud
sponsor of that legislation
the bill does two things first
it tells the department of justice they
need to make consideration of these hate
crimes a top priority during this
pandemic
there's a scourge of abuse happening to
the asian-american community
shamefully aided and abetted by former
president trump
and it needs to be prioritized by law
enforcement
more than it is right now and second
it sends a very important signal from
the congress of the united states to the
american public
these crimes will not be tolerated and
there will
be consequences this legislation
is as common sense and straightforward
as it gets it's as unobjectionable as it
gets
i should expect our work on senator
hirono's hate crimes bill to be
thoroughly bipartisan president biden
has urged congress to swiftly pass this
legislation and send it to his desk
let's get it done this week i attended
four or five maybe even more anti
at rallies against anti-asian violence
and i was heart sick to hear
stories an elderly man just afraid to
walk out on the street
that he might be ridiculed spat upon
a young lady who didn't want to travel
the subways
put some glares and stares from some
people
at her because of her asian ancestry
and the story could be repeated over and
over again and unfortunately this
bigotry often ended in violence
we must stop it as americans we all know
every one of us that racism against one
is racism against all
we must stop it and again i plead with
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle
to let this legislation it seems
so unobjectionable go forward and pass
with strong bipartisan vote again
let's get it done this week on
infrastructure
finally over the last several months the
biden administration has said that it
will push
comprehensive infrastructure and jobs
bill in coordination with the congress
this effort could not come at a better
time the american rescue plan is already
delivering on its promise to lift the
country out of the covid crisis and set
our economy back
on the path to recovery over the state
work period i visited scores of
restaurants
like essies in mount carmel and russo's
grill
in amsterdam that are now receiving a
crucial lifeline of assistance
from the american rescue plan i visited
small and independent stages and venues
like the bug jar in rochester which will
soon receive grants through of the save
our stages act
and i met with community organizations
to hear about how new york families are
receiving thousands of dollars per child
through the expanded tax credit
they will be receiving that and that's a
policy that's going to lift millions of
american children out of poverty
during a time of economic hardship for
so many
the american rescue plan is helping the
country recover from the worst public
health crisis in a century
the worst economic crisis in three
quarters of a century
now not later now is the time to build
on that solid foundation
to create jobs and cement a robust
economy
the next big step is a long overdue
investment
large and significant investment in our
nation's infrastructure
we know that our nation's roads and
bridges and railways and waterways and
ports are in need of an overhaul
so too does our country need investment
in modern infrastructure projects
like our electric grid broadband
internet access and 5g just to name a
few
president biden's proposal will address
both our traditional infrastructure
needs
and invest in 21st century
infrastructure projects that america
sorely needs again
this very important work should be
bipartisan
this is an issue that affects all 50
states
our two parties used to agree on the
need to reliably invest in
infrastructure
we should be able to do that again
president bible
is hosting bipartisan discussions about
his proposal at the white house today
and will continue to bring lawmakers and
stakeholders together to find common
ground
i know that the administration's going
to talk to members from both sides of
the aisle
to incorporate their ideas every day
every day now millions of americans are
getting the vaccine
four million on one day over the weekend
and we're closer than
ever to defeating the covet 19 pandemic
the worst of covet 19 is hopefully in
the rear view mirror
the streets of new york city this
weekend as i wandered about
were more alive than i've seen them in
months
soon we'll have an opportunity to work
together to strengthen our recovery and
create the jobs of the future
a big bold investment in our nation's
infrastructure
is just the way to do it i yield the
floor
adam
as if in legislative session i ask
unanimous consent the senate proceed to
the consideration of h
conres 27 which was received yesterday
which was received today excuse me the
clerk will report
house concurrent resolution 27
permitting the remains of the late
united states capitol police
officer william f evans to lie in honor
of the
attendant of the capitol
is there objection to proceeding to the
matter
without objection the senate will
proceed madam president i ask unanimous
consent the concurrent resolution be
agreed to
and the motion to be reconsidered be
considered made and laid upon the table
with no
intervening action or debate without
objection
madam president as if in legislative
session i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceed to the consideration of h
conres which was received today
28 h conrad's 28 which was received
today
the clerk report pass concurrent
resolution 28
directing the architect of the capital
to transfer the catapult
situation in a capital visitor center to
the pretender
of the capitol for use in connection
with services conducted for united
states capitol police officer
william f evans
is there objection to preceding his
manner
without objection the senate will
proceed i ask unanimous consent the
concurrent resolution be agreed to and
the motion to be reconsidered be
considered made laid upon the table with
no intervening action or debate
without objection
yield the floor
the senator from iowa
thank you very much madam president i
have one short issue
and another issue of about 10 minutes
over the easter break i held a
q a in 24 counties to hear
what's on the minds of iowans it's my
constituent's
agenda not my agenda that we discuss
from my cattle market transparency bill
to the second amendment gun issues
coven 19 vaccines and the crisis at the
southern border
iowans are always up to date on the
issues most important to them
one prominent question why can't you
guys in the senate get along
in other words why not more
bipartisanship
it's a constant question i get iowans
want congress to work in a bipartisan
way
to enhance our nation's infrastructure
through increased funding for roads
bridges highways waterways
and rural broadband among many other
infrastructure issues unfortunately
what i've heard so far about president
biden's plan
is that it's everything but the kitchen
sink
and not enough focus on just the big
big issue and a long-term issue of
infrastructure
iowans expect us to work in a bipartisan
way
and i hope democrats will agree to work
together with us
unlike the passage of the one and nine
tenths
trillion dollar bill
i recently spoke on the senate floor
about the important issue of free speech
today i'd like to speak on the power of
big tech
to censor free speech it's been 25 years
since section 230 of the communications
act was signed into law
this law grants wide sweeping
immunity to interactive communities
computer services that host
third party content the goal of section
230 at the time
was laudable the internet was in its
embassy
and content being posted to message
boards by third parties
was leading to litigation that
threatened the spread
of free speech and free expression
section 230 was enacted to encourage
free speech
while giving companies the ability to
remove
illegals and obscene materials
section 230 and the legal shield it
offers
helped to enable the internet to grow
into what we know this very day
however interactive computer
computer services are no longer
struggling companies
but some of the largest corporations in
the world today
would you believe when section 230 was
signed into law
the words google facebook
twitter and you two did not even exist
as words or companies today
they are giant dominant
tech companies many argue
that these private companies have their
own
terms of service and are able to enforce
them
as they wish and also
that they're not covered under the first
amendment
yet these platforms are now
the new public square where it's
important that all
voices and viewpoints are able to be
heard
with the immunities that these companies
have
and the importance of dialogue on their
platforms
arguably they're in effect
state actors and therefore first
amendment protections
should apply to user generated content
the size and power of these companies
also contributes
to their ability to censor
and undermine the first amendment
google controls 87 percent of search
facebook has 2 and 8 10 billion monthly
active users 500
million tweets are sent on twitter
each day and over
1 billion hours of videos are watched
on youtube every day
when a company has monopoly power
it no longer is constrained by no more
normal market forces
if these plant forms had competitors
consumers could choose alternatives
when they disagree with the terms of
service
or moderation policies
however right now the only choice
consumers have
is to take it or leave it
section 230 appears to compound this
problem
big tech has no competitors and
is immune from liability
these companies are unaccountable to
their customers
the courts and the government
if not for their monopoly power
and section 230 immunity these companies
might not be
involved in the actions and the
censorship
that we see today these platforms are
where people communicate
online and there are no real
alternatives this innovation
has democratized our political system
i think that's good yet there are people
who don't like
that every person is able to get their
views out
and they want to interfere with and
censor those
views we cannot stand
for this canceled culture
and the interference with free speech
entrepreneurs want to challenge these
big tech
companies unfortunately
the system is rigged against the little
guy
startup these companies
can remove their website
from the internet delete your app from
your app store
and permanently ban you from their
platforms
these companies can also remove
competitors
or those that they disagree with largely
with no recourse millions of small
business owners use tech
platforms to operate their business
it's a big been a big boost to our
economy over the last
25 years many
business owners have been censored
banned
and demonetized this can be done without
warning
no explanation whatsoever and many times
without any meaningful due process
so our antitrust regulators
need to take a harder look
at the actions of big tech
i recently introduced legislation with
senator kobachar
to increase resources the ftc
and the doj anti-trust enforcement
this legislation would provide an
immediate boost
to their these these agencies effective
competition responsibilities
right now there are essentially five
companies within just the united states
that determine what can and cannot be
viewed
by the american public it's becoming
increasingly clear that these companies
are more beholding to cancel culture
and not to the free speech principles
that this country was founded upon and
when i talk about what these agencies
the ftc and the doj
ought to be doing i'm not uh
excluding anything that this congress
ought to be doing
beyond what these agencies have a
responsibility to do
so i get back to a famous
quote by justice brandeis
quote if there be time to expose through
discussion
the falsehoods and fallacies to avert
the evil by the process
of education the remedy
to be applied is more speech
not enforced silence
into quote it's time that we examine the
need
for section 230 immunity
that's beyond what we expect doj
and ftc to do
so examine the need for section 230
immunity
and to what extent these tech companies
are abusing
their monopoly power it's time that
these companies stop
arbitrarily deciding what speech is
acceptable
for our country and the 335 million
americans i yield before
madam president i was grateful for the
opportunity like i'm sure we all were to
be back home
for the last two weeks for the state
work period
and to talk to our constituents
some of my conversations and i suspect
i'm not alone
some of these conversations were virtual
but
most uh most of us are glad to get back
to
whatever the next normal is and have
more and more
human interaction rather than the
isolation and
frankly some of the anxiety that comes
along with being
kept apart we're social
animals we human beings and we thrive
on and we i believe need that kind of
interaction but
so far this year most most of it has
been virtual
i did have a chance to speak to the
texas hispanic chamber mentor
members and the members of the u.s
hispanic chamber
as part of their annual legislative
summit
like many of the folks who do fly-ins at
least once a year
we've had to forego that so this was a
virtual
meeting but i did get a chance to hear
from many of the members of their
particular board members on the
importance of our response to the
pandemic
and the progress that they have in turn
been able to make through things like
the paycheck protection
program i also was able to
join friends with the web from webb
county that's laredo texas at
the north american development bank and
their private partners
to announce a 216 million dollar
investment in a new solar farm which
they are very excited about
and i was glad to be able to visit with
a number of texans in person
with all of the appropriate safety
precautions that we've all learned
so well i was able to kick off the
national volunteer month at the san
antonio food bank
with a number of incredible non-profits
and people with big hearts who are
volunteering
even amidst the hopefully the waning
days of this pandemic
at the food bank i hope texans and folks
all across the country will continue to
find ways to support
one another by volunteering with local
non-profits
this month and into the future
i also was able to meet with venue
owners and operators at antones
in austin which is the live music
capital of the world
on the day before applications opened
for the u.s small business
administration
shuttered venue operators grant this
grant program is established through the
save our stages act
which senator klobuchar and i introduced
and which was signed into law
as part of the december relief bill
these small venues were excluded from
the paycheck protection program and of
course we're among the first to close
and we'll be among the last
to open but what we did in the save
our stages act will go a long way to
ensure that the marquees at our most
beloved
live entertainment venues can shine
bright once again
and i'm eager for the funds to reach
texas venues
then in dallas i was i joined my friend
congresswoman eddie bernice johnson to
announce bipartisan legislation
we're introducing in response to the
deadly winter storm that hit
texas last february this legislation
will help build resilience in our
electrical infrastructure throughout the
country
and will help ensure we're better
prepared for whatever
extreme weather mother nature sends our
way
it was great as i said to visit with
folks in person again
and i'm glad to see a great a gradual
return to
our new normal as more and more
americans are vaccinated
even though the issues i'm i was
discussing throughout my state were
different one common theme that i
brought up everywhere i went was to
continue to encourage texans
to get vaccinated so far nine million
of us have received at least one dose of
the vaccine
and 5.6 million texans are fully
vaccinated
obviously we're not out of the woods yet
but americans have every
reason to be optimistic about the
headway made in the fight against cobia
19.
unfortunately just as we're seeing
progress on the pandemic we're seeing
another crisis
on our border in february customs of
border protection encountered more than
100
000 migrants along our southern border
the highest total since 2006.
last month things continued to trend in
the wrong direction
cbp encountered more than 172
000 migrants along our border which is
the highest
in two decades put simply our
immigration system cannot
accommodate this many migrants coming at
one time
we lack the personnel the facilities the
resources
and the policies to efficiently process
these migrants
to make sure those with valid claims
safe for asylum
are protected and to provide quality
care to all of
those in our custody in the meantime
that's true for adults and family units
but especially for the alarming number
of unaccompanied children
in the summer of 2014 we saw a similar
spike
in children arriving at our border which
president obama called a humanitarian
crisis
it absolutely was between october 2013
and september 2014
more than 68 500 unaccompanied children
enter the united states we're only
halfway through fiscal year 2021
and are already reaching that total with
more than 48
500 migrant children having crossed our
border
just in the last six months nearly
nineteen thousand of these children
came last month alone the highest
monthly total
on record putting that in perspective
almost 19
000 children in one month that's roughly
enough
to fill every seat in the a t and t
center in san antonio where the san
antonio spurs play
their grave cascading consequences
to this flow of humanity coming across
our border
it obviously impacts these children as
well as the communities and
organizations that care for them
and of course the criminal organizations
that smuggle people into the country
along with at least illicit drugs
they're getting richer
in the in the process over the last
several weeks i've spent time in these
communities
that are managing this crisis to learn
more about the challenges
that they face last month my friend
henry cuellar
congressman from laredo texas and i
visited the creso springs
influx care facility which is one of the
shelters that houses young
boys aged 13 through 17.
we heard from the men and women who run
the shelter as well as stakeholders in
laredo
elected officials and others ngo
representatives
we heard from them about the mounting
challenges of this crisis
i visited three additional facilities in
midland
dallas and houston during this last work
period and i saw the incredible ways
that these communities
and the non-governmental associations
are caring for migrant children
let me just say madam president we all
recognize
our obligation to treat these children
and these migrants humanely
why they are here in our country but we
also need
to make sure that our laws are equally
enforced on a fair basis
and that people who come this way
don't jump ahead of people who are kind
who've been waiting patiently in line to
come into the united states
through legal means just before the
state
work period started senator cruz and i
hosted
17 of our fellow republican colleagues
in the senate
down into rio grande valley and i was
pleased when i heard
from my friend henry cuellar again that
he had hosted
joe manchin the senator from west
virginia and john hickenlooper
the senator from colorado i'm glad that
members of both parties are coming down
to learn from themselves and listen to
the same experts that i depend on
to give me good information we saw a
facility in donna
where many of these children were first
processed and learned about the
challenges created
by such a high volume of unaccompanied
children
for folks that don't live in a border
state or haven't spent much time in our
border communities
it's important to see the situation
firsthand and to learn from those
experts i mentioned a moment ago
i've worked with folks in the rio grande
valley throughout my time in this
in the senate to ensure that these
communities are safe
prosperous and vibrant places to live
these men and women have valuable
insight for all of us
into the policies that have led to this
crisis and the ones we need
to put in place to turn things around
i appreciate these experts who spent
time sharing their feedback with all of
us
who have been interested enough to
travel to the border
and the colleagues who visited there i'm
glad our colleagues were able to see and
learn more about the unique challenges
facing these communities and our nation
when it comes to uncontrolled
overwhelming
masses of humanity to read news stories
about the thousands of children that are
brought to the united states alone
is heartbreaking to see their faces
though
and learn more about the devastating
circumstances in which they were brought
here
is also nothing short of heartbreaking
at the bailey hutchison convention
center in dallas which is now serving as
a
shelter for 2 300 young boys i
heard from one young boy who arrived in
the united states after a three-month
trek from central america on foot
he told us he spent time hiding in
jungles along the way
and that food was scarce through much of
their journey
as you can imagine he was happy to be in
a safe shelter receiving three square
meals
a day he was understandably soft-spoken
about his long and treacherous journey
and i'm sure he experienced hardships
that you
and i could hardly imagine certainly
circumstances we would never want our
children
or grandchildren to experience last week
some truly disturbing
allegations came out about abuse in one
of the temporary facilities in san
antonio
as i said these children have arrived in
our country after a
perilous journey many arrived sick
malnourished and having endured abuse
including assault along the way the fact
that any of these forms of abuse could
continue while in the care of the united
states government
is despicable i've called on the
inspector general of health and human
services to fully investigate these
allegations
of sexual assault in this facility at
the joe freeman coliseum
i hope the administration will support
our efforts to get to the bottom of what
happened
and ensure that no child is ever
subjected to any level of mistreatment
while in our care the real kicker in all
of this
is that as all of this is unfolding the
coyotes
the smugglers and the cartels that bring
these children
to our border are getting richer and
richer
and richer border patrol said it's
common for families to pay thousands of
dollars
to the coyotes to bring children to
america
with nearly 19 000 caught last month
alone it's easy to see how profitable
this business is
let's say that cartels charge five
thousand dollars ahead
a low estimate based on some of the
figures i've seen
that would mean these criminals brought
in nearly a hundred million dollars
in revenue in march alone just from
smuggling children
these cartels these transnational
criminal organizations
tactics include dropping children as
young as three years old
over the top of a 14 foot segment of the
border wall
or allowing a six-month-old child to be
thrown
from a raft into the rio grande river to
divert border patrol while they
attempt to rescue so they can get on
their way
this has to stop madam president
we can get into an argument about who's
to blame
but that doesn't change the more more
important matter about who has the power
to stop it first president biden needs
to acknowledge the scope of this crisis
and commit to
addressing it along with us in the
congress
all we've gotten from the white house so
far are statements
telling migrants now is not the time to
come
and so they will let everyone know when
the time to come is appropriate
two and a half weeks ago the president
tapped vice president harris to lead
efforts to address this crisis and i
thought this was a sign
that the administration was finally
ready to take some informed action
but the vice president hasn't made a
single trip to the border yet
and there's not even one on the horizon
and then she seemed to walk back that no
her assignment wasn't at the border
it was to engage in diplomacy with
countries in central america
simple statements urging people not to
come are meaningless
when all of the policies represent a
flashing green light that's especially
true when central americans hear
messages from their family and friends
who've made it to america that the door
is wide open
and they will be let in the
administration must take action and
implement policies that discourage
parents from sending their children on
this very perilous
and dangerous journey in the hands of
human smugglers
and criminals into the united states
and we have a big role to play too madam
president
immigration reform has been one of my
greatest frustrations throughout my time
here previous attempts to make lasting
changes led to bills that were so big
that they crumbled under their own
weight i hope we can all agree
that this is not the time to repeat that
history
we need to take action to address the
crisis at hand now
without extraneous matters that could be
and should be
made taking changes made down the line
i'm working with some of our democratic
colleagues to achieve this in and i'm
eager to
share more details soon republicans and
democrats must work together to address
this crisis and to bring order out of
chaos
and to protect the innocent children who
are being harmed
legal immigration has been one of the
one of the cornerstones of our great
country
throughout our history legal immigration
is
generous it's safe it's orderly
and it's fair illegal immigration
and the horrors that it brings along
with it
some of which we learned about on our
recent trips to the to the border
are not humane they are they dishonor
the willingness of people who want to
become
country legally to wait patiently in
line by jumping ahead of them in line
but as i say the cartels and human
smugglers know our laws
and our vulnerabilities better than we
do and they're exploiting it each and
every day
and we've got to bring it to an end
madam president i yield the floor
ohio sorry close enough
thank you madam president i'm here on
the
floor of the senate this evening to talk
about our shared national priorities for
addressing the nation's infrastructure
needs
and my concerns really deep concerns
about the plan the biden administration
has outlined
and specifically the way they intend to
pay for it
i don't think there's a single member in
this chamber who does not recognize the
need for us to invest
in upgrading america's aging
infrastructure
our network of roads bridges and ports
railroads
and more have played an integral role
over the decades in growing our
world-class economy
yet according to a 2019 report the most
recent one we have from the world
economic forum
the united states now ranks only 13th in
the world on infrastructure based on
factors like the quality of our roads
our how efficient our trains are in
access to electricity and water so we
can
and should do more to improve our
infrastructure particularly
as competitors like china make
substantial investments in their own
infrastructure
every year and we can do so
in a bipartisan way just as we have
always done in fact last congress the
senate environment and public works
committee
approved bipartisan infrastructure
legislation by a unanimous vote
of 21 to zero that was just last
congress
21-0 this bipartisan approach last
congress totaled 287 billion dollars
a substantial amount and one we had yet
to figure out how to pay for
the current transportation bill that's
in place the
so-called infrastructure bill from a few
years ago
is about 300 and 10 billion dollars
yet even as we have to figure out how to
fund the bipartisan
287 billion dollar package for roads and
bridges from last year
a substantial amount in its own right
the biden administration recently
introduced its own infrastructure plan
that totals 2.7
trillion dollars almost 10 times
as much at the core of this biden
administration proposal
is 620 billion dollars in infrastructure
broadly defined it's a generous
definition of roads and bridges and
other physical
transportation and water components that
have traditionally been considered
infrastructure
so a generous definition would be that
out of the 2.7
trillion dollars 620 billion could be
called infrastructure
based on the way republicans and
democrats alike have always looked at it
and again that would include water
electricity
other forms of transportation not just
roads and bridges
so about 20 percent of the
biden administration infrastructure bill
actually fits the bill
the reason the overall package costs 2.7
trillion dollars
is because they have included a broad
set of liberal priorities that are a far
cry from what has ever been defined
as infrastructure by either democrats or
republicans
so i guess knowing the popularity of
infrastructure
and it is popular people want to see
their roads and bridges repaired
the biden administration has simply
redefined the word to include hundreds
of billions of dollars
of spending on priorities like health
care
federal office buildings and other
facilities research and development
electric vehicle manufacturers and more
according to the biden administration
paid leave is now infrastructure
child care is now infrastructure care
giving
is now infrastructure while many are
worthy causes
and should be debated and voted on
separately
they don't belong in infrastructure
bills
this approach is troubling to me and i
know to many of my colleagues
some on both sides of the aisle because
it's a continuation of the raw
partisanship that defined
the latest covet 19 spending package
back in march
rather than work to find good faith
negotiations with republicans to craft a
package that could gain bipartisan
support
the biden administration and senate
democrats apparently are once again
looking into potentially using
reconciliation to jam republicans
to pass another trillion-dollar plus
spending bill
with a simple 50-vote majority
and like covet 19 infrastructure
has always been bipartisan so if you
can't be bipartisan
on covet 19 and you can't be bipartisan
in
infrastructure what can you be
bipartisan about
this partisan approach by the way is the
opposite of what president biden pledged
on the campaign trail and in his
inauguration address
in his inaugural address he talked about
the need to get back to more
bipartisanship
and urged unity i agreed with that
assessment and said so at the time
unfortunately he has apparently listened
to the more strident voices in his party
and has gone down the partisan path as
with the 1.9 trillion dollar coveted
spending package last march
the end result could be another spending
bill
that is far higher than it needs to be
at a time of record debt
and deficits and another partisan bill
that further divides us at a time when
we are already
too divided in fact about a quarter of
the biden plan is not paid for at all
taking us further into debt but even
more troubling
to me is that the democrats plan to pay
for roughly
two trillion dollars of this plan with
massive
tax increases on american workers and
consumers
and by making us less competitive in the
global economy
this would completely reverse the
progress we've made over the past few
years in making america competitive
again
thanks to the 2017 tax reforms that the
biden proposal would largely dismantle
in the couple of years before covet 19
we saw
record growth in jobs and wages with the
lowest poverty rate
since the federal government started
keeping track of it 60 years ago
in promoting the biden tax increases
treasury secretary janet yellen
claims we need to reverse the 2017 tax
reforms because they encouraged
businesses to move jobs out of the
country
the reality is just the opposite the
2017
tax reforms stopped the so-called
corporate tax inversions which caused
american companies to become foreign
companies
and move jobs and investment out of
america because
of our uncompetitive tax laws this
happened to a number of companies in
ohio
and in every state practically
represented in this chamber
the 2017 reforms also stopped the
lockout effect that kept foreign profits
of u.s companies overseas they weren't
bringing the profits back
instead 1.6 trillion dollars
in overseas earnings has come back to
the united states and was invested right
here
at home most importantly for working
families 70
of the savings from the corporate tax
cuts went into workers wages
contributing to 19 straight months
of wage growth of over 3 percent
annually
that we enjoyed before the pandemic this
wage growth was really welcome in my
home state of ohio
we had lower wages or flat wages for
more than a decade
and by the way who benefited most from
this wage increase 19 straight months of
wage increases
lower and middle income workers exactly
what
should have been happening thanks to the
2017 reforms the largest u.s companies
also increased their domestic
research and development expenditures by
25
which amounts to 707 billion dollars
more
r d and they further increase capital
expenditures by 20
aided by this return of foreign profits
all of this u.s investment job creation
and new r d would be put at risk by
these proposed tax hikes
under the biden plan which we've heard
is raising the corporate rate from 21
to 28 percent in actuality
the combined federal and state corporate
rate would go
from 25.8 percent where it is now when
you include the state and federal
other countries like china don't have
any state income tax on their
corporations
they just have the federal rate so we've
go we'd be going from 25.8 percent
by the way which is already above the
average of 23.4 percent for other
developed countries
so-called oecd countries it would go
from 25.8
up to a staggering 32.8 percent
the highest rate in the developed world
our tax rate would once again be higher
than china's
and higher than any country in the
developed world japan
europeans this is exactly what we got
away from in 2017
and it's what on a bipartisan basis
there was a consensus for us to do
maybe not the exact rate but the idea
was to make america competitive again
i co-chaired a task force with a fellow
senator
a democrat from across the aisle chuck
schumer
on the finance committee and we came up
with this idea of saying
let's go to a territorial type tax
system
and let's lower the rate so that we can
be competitive around the world and it's
what happened
and it's working and now for some reason
the biden administration says
we want to reverse all that these abrupt
tax hikes
which actually would be five times as
large as corresponding corporate tax
cuts in 2017
would make our workers and our
businesses less competitive globally
at a time when our economy's just
starting to recover
the biden plan goes well beyond just
making our tax rates uncompetitive again
it also doubles the tax on so-called
global intangible
low tax income or guilty
making it more costly for u s companies
to operate
outside the united states more costly
than any other
countries companies of any developed
country in the world again
it puts us at a competitive disadvantage
it unfairly punishes
american workers who have their jobs
here in america
supporting international operations
in ohio for example we have procter
campbell it's headquartered in my
hometown
they rely on oversea production to serve
foreign markets in an affordable manner
they're not going to ship
diapers from here overseas because it's
not
cost competitive so for the foreign
markets they'll make diapers in those
foreign countries
however by doing so they employ
thousands of ohioans
and others around this country who
support those international sales
so all the back office work the sales
work the research and development so on
is done here
the proposed biden tax increases would
make such companies
uncompetitive overseas resulting in us
losing markets there and losing u.s jobs
remember no other developed country in
the world does this except us
no other country taxes these companies
on their
foreign profits
we got away from that on purpose and we
essentially established a minimum tax
which
again hardly any country in the world
has but we wanted to have
some balance here now under this
proposal from the biden administration
that tax would be more than doubled
it's going to hurt us the biden
administration also proposes to
eliminate a provision
regarding what's called foreign derived
and tangible income fdii
in 2017 we put ftii in place for a very
simple reason and there seemed to be a
consensus about that which is
to provide a carrot to us companies to
do their research and development here
in america
it incentivized companies to bring that
research back
and to keep that research here
it worked to create high skill and
high-wage jobs
for example google cisco
facebook brought all of their
intellectual property home
all of their ip home and we hear from
other u.s companies like intel
and disney who say they kept their ip in
the united states
due to this tax law change why would we
want that to go overseas
the biden administration claims that it
wants the united states to be more
competitive
yet these proposed tax increases do just
the opposite
it makes no sense that while china and
other countries are increasing subsidies
to businesses that innovate
the united states would be punishing our
workers and global companies making them
less competitive in what amounts to an
astounding admission of how deeply
flawed these proposals are
when treasury secretary janet yellen
announced a proposal to increase taxes
we've just talked about
she actually went out of her way to make
a plea
to other countries around the world she
asked them to raise their own corporate
tax rates to increase their own taxes
to ensure as she said a more level
playing field
understanding the nature of the intense
global competition our competitors are
doing
just the opposite it's naive to think
that because
we're going to raise our taxes
and ask them to do the same that they
would do that
they want more of the jobs and
investment in their country
in fact just this past week the finance
minister of ireland when asked about
this said no they have no interest in
raising taxes
and ireland is one of those countries
it's made themselves competitive and
resulted
in our tax law changes because they were
taking jobs away from us
and now we were bringing this ip and
these jobs back
ireland china these other countries
they're going to continue to lower
barriers to attract capital
and jobs it's wishful thinking at best
to think because we're going to raise
our taxes they're going to raise theirs
the biden plan would mean america
standing alone atop
the corporate tax rate chart among all
developed countries
standing alone leaving our businesses
and workers to suffer the cost
a fact worn out from multiple studies
including from the non-partisan
congressional budget office that shows
that it is workers
who bear most of the burden of higher
taxes in the form of lower wages
and lost jobs it's not the corporations
it's the workers as i said before
there's a clear need for us to reinvest
in american infrastructure i think we
can all agree at that
republicans and democrats alike want to
do it and right now in the key committee
of jurisdiction by the way the
senate environmental and public works
committee bipartisan negotiations are
ongoing
this is the same committee that had a
unanimous vote last congress
on the transportation legislation
they're talking right now
about how to put together a bipartisan
package that's the
right way to do it through regular order
allow democrats republicans alike to
offer their ideas
there's also a group of republicans and
democrats outside of the committee who
have met
and are looking for a more sensible way
forward i'm among that group
there are others as well the partisan
approach by the biden administration
looks to be taking us down the road of
another trillion dollar plus spending
package
jammed through congress with no support
from the other side of the aisle that's
not good
for this institution it's not good for
this country it's not the way to get
things done
instead of a 2.7 trillion dollar plan
that goes way beyond any reasonable
definition
of infrastructure and is mostly paid for
with a devastating tax hike on u.s
workers in our economy
let's do what we know works a bipartisan
approach
focus on what we have all agreed is
infrastructure roads
bridges ports rail broadband other true
infrastructure i believe if we take that
more
targeted approach we can build on the
bipartisan frameworks this congress has
achieved in recent years
and work together to find common sense
ways to fund
infrastructure legislation including
user fees which is what we've always
used in the past
without resorting to partisan tax hikes
which reduce the competitiveness
of u.s workers u.s companies and
undermined
investment in our country
i hope we take that better approach and
yield back my time
madam president senator from tennessee
thank you madam president
we've just listened to senator portman
and you're hearing
others of us on the republican side of
the aisle
talk about the elevated levels of
spending
and how our democratic colleagues have
seemed to lose
touch with the american people this is
something that
appears to have happened at lightning
speed
it really began on the very first
day of the biden administration it
started with the stroke of a pen
and a stream of executive
orders on day one
president biden made a decision that he
would weaken our border
and with that stroke of a pen
he destroyed hundreds
hundreds thousands of good
paying union jobs right in the middle
of a pandemic and that was by
eliminating the keystone pipeline with
every decision he has made it abundantly
clear that he came back to washington
not to serve this country but to advance
an agenda pushed by the most
radical left wing of the democratic
party that being said
the white house has a problem because
the american people
have figured out what they are up to
and as i have been home for the past
couple of weeks
i have talked to tennesseans from
every political division
they're democrats republicans
independents
they're unaffiliated they're concerned
citizens
and it bothers them what they're seeing
from this white house
how could they not have after seeing
senate democrats
spend 1.9 trillion dollars
on coronavirus relief that spent just
nine percent of that price tag
on testing and health care jobs if that
didn't do it
president biden surely pipped them off
when he nominated a health and
human services secretary with no
health care experience xero
and a homeland security secretary
who believes that we should have
unsecured
borders you cannot make this up
people are astounded with this
so when people back home in tennessee
saw president biden's
latest proposal for a 2 trillion dollar
so-called infrastructure bill they
weren't particularly shocked to see
that very little of this legislation has
to do
with infrastructure just three months
into the new administration and already
they know
this is just another vehicle for the
left's
wish list the most frustrating thing
about
it is that tennesseans have repeatedly
told
me that a smart targeted
plan to fund infrastructure improvements
would make a tremendous difference in
local communities and in our state they
support that type investment they want
to see
that roads bridges
waterways highways
broadband airports they're for that
what they don't support is an
administration that repeatedly promises
one thing
and then chooses to do
the opposite just like last month's
over-the-top spending bill this month's
multi-trillion dollar boondoggle isn't
just a
waste of taxpayer dollars it's a missed
opportunity
to rebuild parts of our economy that
were struggling
to keep up before the pandemic hit
here's a number for your talking points
less than six percent
and what is less than six percent
madam president that is
the amount that's the percentage
of this two trillion dollar bill
that actually goes to infrastructure
projects less than six percent
tennesseans are asking me how could this
possibly happen
we've been talking about having
an infrastructure bill now
for about three years and you bring a
bill forward
the democratic leadership does and
less than six percent goes to
infrastructure now
this sounds like a familiar tactic
redefine your standards put less than 10
percent
of your funding toward your stated
purpose
then throw the rest into yet another
handout for projects
that would not stand a chance
they wouldn't have a snowball's chance
of receiving public support on their own
much less 60 votes here in this chamber
president biden's american jobs plan
ignores
rural tennesseans who have to navigate
flood plains to get to work or to get to
school
it bypasses crumbling bridges
they can't avoid but it sure does
pay a lot of attention to green new deal
policies
that were non-starters even before
speaker pelosi lost ground
in the house climate change studies
and union payouts take precedent
over roads bridges ports airports
and waterways in fact this absurd
scheme spends more taxpayer money on
electric
cars than on all of those
things combined yes
you heard me correctly
this so-called infrastructure bill
spends more money
more of your hard-earned tax dollars on
electric cars than
on all of the roads
bridges highways ports airports
and waterways that is correct
another day another power grab made
worse by
job destroying corporate tax increases
that will put
american companies at a global
disadvantage
it's no wonder democrats have been
working overtime to stretch the
definition of infrastructure
past the point of reason these days
entire white house press briefings rely
on the idea
that the definition of infrastructure
will continue to
evolve as they say
it's going to evolve to make it include
whatever the democrats decide
that it should include it's a
time-honored
liberal trick that has run its course
they can tweet that lie every day for
the next four years
if they choose but here in the real
world
we're dealing with an economy still in
recovery major industries in crisis
and millions of families who are working
terribly hard and long hours
to just make ends meet what we're seeing
here
isn't just a disconnect this is
an administration attempting to impose
their socialist
vision on a country that cannot sustain
the cost to my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle
i want to be clear that vision of
america
that you have invented to fulfill this
purpose
does not exist
it's time to come up for air and talk a
little reality i know it's a popular
thing here in washington
to claim that elections have
consequences
but on your first day back in power the
democratic party got together
and marched right across the line that
separates
consequences from punishment
punishment that's what they're all about
i would also encourage my democratic
colleagues to remember
that when they do this when they put
together
these trillion dollar handouts for
radical special
interest political pain for their
opponents
isn't the only result
they are punishing their neighbors
their friends communities
that are in their states they're making
life
harder much more difficult
for local businesses and small business
manufacturers
and they're exposing our weaknesses
to our adversaries i will tell you madam
president
if president biden and the majority
leader
shoved yet another blank check
through this chamber they're going to
find out in a hurry
i really do believe how little
the american people have to give
for their leftist agenda i yield the
floor
madam president i know the sense of the
quorum
call the role
ms baldwin
without
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on the nomination of executive
counter number 55
polly allen trottenberg of new york to
be deputy secretary of transportation
signed by 17 senators by unanimous
consent the mandatory quorum call has
been waived
the question is is it the sense of the
senate that debate on the nomination of
paulie allen trottenberg of new york
to be deputy secretary of transportation
shall be brought to a close
the yeas and mays are mandatory under
the rule the clerk will call the rule
ms baldwin mr barrasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr bozeman mr braun
mr brown mr burr
miss cantwell this is capital mr cardin
mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy who's calling
mr coons
mr cornyn
miss cortez masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
cruz
mr danes
this is duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
this is gillibrand
mr graham
mr grassley
mr haggerty
miss hassan
mr holly
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hubbard
this is hyde smith
strain huh
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss clavichar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr luhan
miss lomas
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
ms murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters mr portman
mr reed
mr rift
mr romney
miss rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr seth
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema
miss smith
miss davenaugh
mr sullivan
mr tester
mr then
mr tillis
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
is warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
cardin
carper cortes masto duckworth
durbin feinstein gillibrand heinrich
hickenlooper hirono inhofe
king leahy menendez ossoff
peters reed rosen schatz
schumer cinema smith stabenow
van hollen warner young
mr wyden i
miss warren i senators voting in the
negative
blackburn braun paul
tuberville
mr scott mr scott of south carolina
no mr graham mr graham
no
mr graham mr graham
i
mr rounds mr rounds i
you
mr booker mr booker i
mrs capital mrs capito
i mr blunt mr blunt aye mr sanders mr
sanders
aye mr crapo mr crapo
aye mr tester mr tester
i
gained kane i
mr marshall mr marshall i
mrs shaheen mr shaheen
i
mr luhan mr lujan i
mr whitehouse mr whitehouse i
mr cotton mr cotton
aye
mr hawley mr hawley no
miss collins miss collins i
miss baldwin miss baldwin aye mr kelly
mr kelly
i
mr burr mr burr aye
mr romney mr romney
mr padilla mr padilla i
mr markley mr markley i
mr shelby mr shelby
no miss klobuchar miss klobuchar
i
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith aye
you
mr kennedy mr kennedy now
mr grassley mr grassley aye mr bozeman
mr boseman
aye
mr mansion mr mansion aye
mr cantwell miss cantwell i
this
mr bennett mr bennett i
mr markey mr markey i
mr johnson mr johnson aye mr lee mr lee
no
mr cassidy mr cassidy
i
mr danes mr danes no mr risch mr risch
i mr toomey mr toomey aye
mr coons mr coons aye mr blumenthal mr
[Music]
blumenthal
mr lankford mr lankford aye
uh
you
mr murphy mr murphy i
mr brown mr brown i
mr warnock mr warnock i
mr kramer mr kramer aye
mr casey mr casey i
mr hagerty mr hagerty no
mr wicker mr wicker i
ms ernst miss ernst i
mr thune mr thune i mr scott mr scott of
florida
no mr cornyn mr cornyn
i
mrs fisher mrs fisher i
mr sass mr says aye ms hassan miss
hassan
i mr hovind mr hoeven
i
mr barrasso mr barrasso i
you
mr portman mr portman i'm
mr cruz mr cruz no
mr sullivan mr sullivan aye
you
uh
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell i
on this vote the yeaser 81 the nasir 14
the motion is agreed to
mr president senator from ohio
thank you mr president on friday amazon
one of the world's largest corporations
successfully crushed the most recent
union drive at one of their warehouses
where workers are organizing for a voice
in the job let's be clear
this was never a fair fight amazon is
perhaps the world's most powerful
corporation
they would not be raking in profits
without the hard work and dedication
of its hundreds hundreds of thousands of
american workers
yet amazon unleashed all that corporate
power
to fight those same workers they
harassed employees with anti-union
propaganda
they sent misleading text messages and
websites and flyers
works workers reported they don't even
get enough time to go to the bathroom
to get enough time for bathroom breaks
in the warehouse that's how intense the
company's pressure is
and yet when they're able to use the
bathroom during this
union fight even there workers are hit
with anti-union propaganda flyers
on the stall doors amazon demanded the
u.s postal service install a mailbox on
site
at the warehouse so they could monitor
employees mailing their union election
ballots
it's all part of the pattern for amazon
in 2019
amazon fired a union a staten island
warehouse worker who called for
unionization
amazon monitors employees online
communications last fall
we learned the company planned to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars
on new software to monitor threats
like unions amazon isn't alone this
union busting is standard operating
procedure
for most companies a growing number of
americans want to join unions
a recent poll found that about half of
americans would like to join a union if
they could
millennials are the most pro-worker
pro-union generation
since world war ii the center for
economic policy and research
reported that 75 of new union members
are under the age of 35. i talked to one
of those union workers at the end of
last month
i spoke to kate from zanesville ohio who
joined
ufcw united food and commercial workers
not too long ago
we talked about the work she and i
and others did to save her future
pension and the rescue plan
how her union has helped her learn about
retirement security
and helped her fight for her retirement
security so if all those workers
especially young workers
want to join a union if they want to
have a voice in the job they want to
have
more control over their work lives why
aren't more union drive successful
pretty important question to ask pretty
obvious answer
because corporations have so much power
one
union organizer told a reporter for the
huffington post when people hear there's
an election
they think everybody gets to vote
there's a secret ballot and so on
what they don't understand what the
public doesn't understand about union
elections
is that the company has access to the
workers 24 hours a day
seven days a week has enormous influence
over their lives
if they care to to to use that influence
and so often they do
here's what he said they can threaten
they can give a raise they can demote
they can grant favors
or they cannot grant favors every worker
knows that
this is what workers organizing are up
against there's nothing
close nothing at all resembling a level
playing field
for american workers that's why we need
the pro act
protecting the right to organize that
comprehensive over all of our labor laws
to protect workers right to stand
together and to bargain for fair wages
and better benefits
in safer workplaces it would level the
playing field finally
finally mr president give workers a
fighting chance against corporate
union busting tactics like we saw from
amazon we know what's happened in this
country
we know we've seen we've seen worker
productivity
go up we've seen corporate profits go up
we've seen executive compensation
skyrocket upward yet
worker wages are flat passing the pro
act would strengthen the punishment
against worker against companies that
violate workers rights to organize
and then retaliate against union
organizers it would it would close
loopholes
that allow employers to misclassify
their employees
as supervisors and independent
contractors to avoid paying their fair
share
and to avoid giving workers the benefits
they have
earned and that they deserve a union
card is a ticket to a middle-class life
when you fight for economic justice by
making it available
for all workers we just need
corporations to get out of the way to be
neutral
to let workers organize and take control
over their careers and their futures
we also need to empower all workers
whether they chose them to join a union
or not
that means paid family and medical leave
for all workers means a living wage for
all workers
means retirement security for all
workers it means power over your life
and your schedule it means overtime pay
when you earn it
it means health care for all workers
it's all in the end mr president
about the dignity of work remember what
dr king said
that no labor is really meaningful no
labor is menial
unless you're not getting adequate wages
when you love this country you fight for
the people who make it work
that's what union organizers do in the
face of overwhelming corporate
opposition
like the billionaires at amazon and it's
what all of us must continue to do
until all work pays off
mr president i ask that the following
comments be inserted a
different place in the record without
objection thank you mr president
i'd like to honor a long time member of
my ohio staff matt keys
matt's last day in our office is
tomorrow before he moves on to a new
opportunity
still in ohio still serving the people
of my state
still serving the state that he and i
both love
matt's been with our office for seven
years working with ohio reporter porters
to inform the public traveling the state
with me to hear
from ohioans we've been to diners and
drive-throughs we've done press
conferences in front of small businesses
and schools and bridges
before the pandemic we spent hours in
crowded union halls
matt has earned the respect of so many
ohio reporters he understands
how important their work is to ohio
communities
he understands reporters and their
contribution to democracy
something we wouldn't have even had to
have bothered say five years ago
he knows every news source in ohio he's
built relations with the
principal dedicated journalists who run
them he has a deep understanding of our
state
matt knows ohio as well as anyone he
went to college here he stayed in ohio
he dedicates his life to making our
state a place where other young people
want to stay too
some of the most memorable events matt
and i have been together
have been rallies and meetings with
workers
and retirees around my state fighting to
save their pensions
it's fitting that matt ends his time in
our office
with a huge victory for ohio workers
literally tens and tens and tens of
thousands
of ohio families benefiting from the
work we all did together as activists
that matt did that my staff did the rest
of my staff that we did together
to in the american rescue plan to save
the pensions that ohioans
earned over a lifetime of work matt got
to know these leaders in these activists
over the years people
like rita lewis and mike walden and dana
varga
he didn't just listen to their stories
about what it would mean
to their families to lose their
retirement security lifted up their
voices
that's what somebody like matt that's
what matt keys does that's what good
journalists do
that's what good communications people
do they listen
to their stories about what this
situation means to their families
then they lift up their voices they
share those stories
with the media and with the country it's
how we got congress to listen
it's how we finally got that done that's
the lesson
of matt keys for young reporters for
young journalists
for young communications directors for
young people that want to make a living
doing this i'll miss matt
on the road in ohio i know he'll
continue to serve our state
i know he'll continue to fight for the
dignity of work in
everything that he does matt we will
miss you
mr president senator from ohio i ask
unanimous consent the senate proceed to
legislative session and be in
in a period of morning business with
senators permitted to speak therein
for up to 10 minutes each with that
objection
thank you mr president i ask you to ask
consent that when the senate completes
its business today
it adjourn until 12 noon tuesday april
13th
that following the prayer and the pledge
the morning hour be deemed expired the
journal proceedings
be approved to date the time for the two
leaders be reserved for their use later
in the day
and morning business be closed that upon
the conclusion of morning business the
senate proceed to executive session
to resume consideration of the
nomination of polly trottenberg to be
deputy secretary of transportation
further i asked at the senate recess
from 12 30
until 2 15 to allow for the weekly
caucus meetings
finally mr president that the
post-cloture time in the trottenberg
nomination
be considered expired at 2 15 pm
is there objection without objection
if there's no further business mr
president come before the senate i ask
that it stand adjourned under the
previous order
senate stands adjourned until 12 noon
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you